안녕하세요 기술로트 알렉입니다. 요즘 다들 잘 지내시나요?
굉장히 빠르게 변하는 이 ai 시대 조금만 당황스럽고 무엇을 해야 될지
좀 감이 안 잡히고 너무 많은 정보들을 그리고 ai 쉽게 모든 것을 해버리는 이 시간에
저는 다시 한번 기본을 강조하고 싶습니다. 물론 이제 바이브 코딩도 너무 좋고 너무 잘 되어 있지만
기본을 좀 충실하게 해 두는 것이 어떤 도구를 사용할 때도 그것을 더 잘 활용할 수 있는 방법이라고 생각합니다.
이전 영상에서 네트워크가 정말 중요하다고 했는데 사실은 더 중요한 것이 데이터베이스다 라고 한번 더 강조하고 싶습니다.
물론 다 중요하죠 다 중요한데 네트워크는 아무래도 이제 통신기반으로 네트워크 기반으로 앱이 구동되고
대부분의 서비스가 이렇게 이루어지때문에 당연히 알아야 되는 거인데 데이터베이스도 한 당연히 항상 필요합니다.
그러니까 이제 알아야 될 범위가 넓어졌다 라는 정도로 생각하시면 될 것 같고 저는 계속 주장하기를
깊이 있게 모든 것을 이렇게 하나하나 배워가면서 쌓아갈 것보다는 조금은 다소 가볍게 전체를 이해하면서 내가 필요한 것들을
찾아서 더 공부하는 그래서 약간 제 표현으로 탑다운 구조로 공부하시기를 말씀드렸는데 마찬가지입니다. 데이터베이스 오늘 굉장히 간단한 내용으로
말씀드릴 예정입니다. 데이터베이스라는 것은
보통 이렇게 많이 그리는데 데이터베이스라는 것은 아주 쉽게 말하면 데이터가
저장되는 그런 곳입니다. 데이터가 저장되는 이것은 소프트웨어
데이터베이스라는 것에 표현해 몇 가지 뜻이 있을 수 있는데 데이터베이스 자체는 이러한 형태를 데이터베이스라고 다 할 수 있고요.
또 이 데이터들을 담고 있는 그런 소프트웨어들을 데이터베이스라고도 합니다. 이거는 대표적으로
가장 많이 쓰는 것이 마이애스케일, 몰아클 이런 것들이 있고요. 몽고디비
그리고 좀 현업이라든가 이렇게 기업에서는 데이터베이스를 물리적인 장비 레벨로도 표현을 하기도 해요.
그러니까 아키텍처상에서 데이터베이스다 그러면 이제 하드웨어까지 하지만 하드웨어는 그냥 컴터라고 보면 돼요.
컴터라고 보면 되고 다만 그런 구성도까운데 데이터베이스 서버라고 하면 물리적인 얘기까지 살짝 포함하기도 한다.
이 물리적인 서버는 그냥 단순히 서버이고 이러한 것들이 설치되어져 있다 라고 보시면 됩니다.
데이터베이스를 저장하는 형태를 보면 조금 난이긴 합니다.
여기까지 같이 그냥 편하게 설명드리면 여기는 노예스케일 디비라고 해서 좀 비정형 데이터들을 저장하고 활용하는 데이터베이스가 있고
여기는 에스케일 정형이라고 하는 관계형 데이터베이스들을 말합니다.
그러면 노예스케일 기반들은 조금 이해를 천천히 해도 되는 영역이고요.
rdb 먼저 얘기를 하면 rdb는 관계형 데이터베이스라고 생각하시면 되고 그 관계의 중심에는 데이터를 저장하고 어떤 방식으로 저장하냐.
예를 들면 테이블에 저장한다. 데이터들을 그리고 테이블 간에는 이런 어떤 관계를 가진다 라는 정도로 아주 쉽게 생각을 해보시면 될 것 같고요.
데이터베이스라는 것이 이러한 소프트웨어다 라고 했고 그 안에 또 데이터베이스라는 논리적인 또 개념이 있습니다.
데이터베이스를 이런 디비 안에서 또 나눠요. 데이터베이스라고.
그것은 이제 이 하나의 데이터베이스 소프트웨어 안에 여러 개의 데이터 묶음들이 들어갈 수 있다라고 보는 거죠.
데이터베이스 이름도 정할 수 있고요. 이렇게 하나 들어가고 또 여러 개가 들어갈 수 있어요.
마치 컴퓨터 폴더처럼 아니면 드라이브처럼 구분해서 다루어지는 개념 논리적으로 나누는 거고 이 데이터베이스 하위에는 테이블이라는 개념이 있습니다.
테이블 안에 들어가는 거고 테이블에는 이제 레코드라고 해서 행이라는 개념이 있고 항목이라는 개념이 있습니다.
이거는 마치 어떤 걸 생각하면 가장 좀 이해하기 쉽냐면 엑셀 같은 것을 상상하면 좋아요.
엑셀을 딱 생각해보면 물론 빈칸만 있지만 이렇게 쭉 있죠. 쭉 있는데 이 엑셀이 사실 엑셀로도 많이 저장을 하기도 했죠.
그리고 지금도 많이 사용되죠. 이런 식으로 그러면 예를 들면 이게 회원이라는 개념은 항상 어디나 있으니까 회원이 있고
상품이 있을 수 있고요. 상품이 있을 수 있고 주문이 있을 수 있습니다.
예를 들면 이런 것들의 데이터를 이렇게 회원, 상품, 주문 이런 식으로 따로 저장하는 개념이 일단은 테이블이다.
그러면 회원 테이블이라는 게 있고 상품 테이블이라는 게 있고 주문 테이블이라는 게 있다는 거예요.
관계형이라는 의미에서 이제 생각해보면 회원은 회원 데이터만 이 테이블에 저장을 하게 됩니다.
이때 회원에 예를 들면 아이디가 있을 수 있고요.
패스워드는 지겹적으로 저장을 잘 하지 않지만 어쨌든 패스워드 그러니까 저장을 하지만 암호화를 하는 거죠.
그런 게 있을 수 있고 전화번호, 주소 이렇게 있다면 이렇게 항목들이 있는 거고
그러면 회원, 일본 회원에 값이 여기 쭉 들어가는 거고 2줄에는 회원 2, 여기는 회원 3.
이런 식으로 쭉 들어가는 거죠. 쭉 밑으로.
그런 식으로 저장된다는 개념과 유사합니다. 엑셀에도 이렇게 저장할 수 있죠.
그런 것처럼 여기에 테이블에 이렇게 저장이 되는 겁니다.
그래서 이 한 줄 한 줄이 하나의 데이터인 거죠. 회원 하나의 정보고 회원 하나의 정보고
그렇게 되면 이 회원 하나의 정보를 레코드라고 하고요.
여기 아이디나 패스워드, 전화번호 이런 것들을 column이라고 합니다.
스플링 일부러 약간 흐리는 느낌. column, column.
그러면 이런 식으로 데이터가 쭉 쌓이고 이제 또 상품에 대한 정보가 있을 수 있죠.
상품 이름, 여기에 상품 아이디, 상품의 가격 이런 게 쭉 있으시죠.
그러면 이런 형태처럼 상품도 이렇게 만들어서 저장을 한다는 거예요.
주문은 어떻게 되냐면 주문은 뭐하고 할까요? 회원과 상품의 연결이 필요하겠죠.
주문을 한다는 것은 어떤 회원이 어떤 상품을 주문했다.
물론 여기서 조금 더 들어가면 이 데이터베이스 테이블을 설계한다고 해서
어떤 식으로 관계할 것인가를 좀 치밀하게 설계를 해줘야 되는 부분이 있습니다.
물론 있습니다. 예를 들면 이렇게 회원과 상품 이렇게 제가 표현을 했지만 이렇게 바로 하지 않고
따로 예를 들면 오더 디테일 이런 식으로 이름을 하고
중간에서 회원과 상품을 연결해주는 이런 테이블을 별도로 만드는 편이죠. 그렇게 만들어야 되기도 하고요.
그거는 조금 복잡한 얘기니까 일단 여기까지를 이해한다는 처음에서
이런 식으로 테이블에 데이터들을 저장합니다. 라는 거예요.
그리고 이 관계에서 이렇게 예를 들면 회원이 있고요. 회원 테이블이 있었어요.
회원이 주문을 한 개만 할 수 있을까요. 그냥 오더 디테일을 쓸게요.
이런 이름은 그냥 정해진 게 아닙니다. 테이블 이름은 마치 변수명을 정하듯이 정하는 거예요.
멤버라고도 할 수 있죠. 유저라고도 할 수 있겠죠.
그건 의미로 정하면 됩니다. 그 테이블의 데이터를 잘 가르칠 수 있는 거면 돼요.
이 회원이 어떤 상품을 하나만 주문할 수 있나요. 여러 개가 가능하죠.
그러면 회원 하나는 이렇게 출발하고 얘가 여러 개를 이렇게 관계매줄 수 있겠죠.
이게 표현이에요. 관계형 디비를 서로 테이블 간에 관계를 나타낼 때
이렇게 쭉 그려나가는 거 꽤 복잡해집니다.
실제 서비스를 만져보면 이런 것을 ERD라고 합니다.
이렇게 테이블 안에 들어가는 내용들 그것을 레코드 그리고 하나하나의 컬럼들 항목들로 조정이 된다는 개념이 RDB.
그래서 이거를 간단하게 보기 쉽게 정리를 하는 게 있습니다.
마찬가지로 계속 보고 있는 기술로트 PDF 도서이고요. 거기서 이렇게 정리를 해놨습니다.
설명드린 내용인데 한번 정리를 해보면 아주 간단한 레벨이에요.
데이터베이스라는 개념이 있고 데이터베이스는 데이터를 저장하는 소프트웨어다.
그리고 거기에 논리적으로 서비스별로 데이터베이스라는 것으로 생성을 해서 사용한다는 거예요.
이거 실제 데이터베이스 도구에서 한번 보여드릴게요.
그리고 테이블이 만들어지는 거고 테이블은 여러 개가 계속 만들어질 수 있습니다.
의미적으로 여기 회원 테이블, 상품 테이블, 주문 테이블 이런 식으로 의미적으로 데이터들이 쭉 쌓인다.
그게 테이블이고 이 테이블은 하나하나의 이런 식으로 레코드 한 줄 한 줄 이렇게
그리고 항목이 하나하나가 칼럼이라는 형태로 아이디가 있을 수 있고 회원 이름이 있을 수 있고 여러 가지 전화번호나
이거의 이 의미에 필요한 항목들을 여기다 넣어서 이렇게 쌓는다라는 겁니다.
이것들을 이 데이터를 이렇게 쌓는다라는 표현을 했을 때 이것을 다 SQL이라는 일종의 언어인데 문법이에요.
데이터베이스를 조작할 수 있는 문법입니다.
이런 식의 명령어들을 통해서 데이터베이스를 조작할 수 있습니다.
조작이라는 단어가 좀 불편하게 들 수 있지만 뭐 하여튼 데이터를 넣거나 지우거나 읽거나 하는 것들을 할 수 있다는 거죠.
그것이 SQL이라는 겁니다. 그래서 SQL을 공부한다는 것은 이렇게 데이터베이스를 좀 컨트롤 하거나 데이터를 조작할 때 필요하다.
간단히는 여기까지만 좀 이해해도 괜찮고요.
테이블을 생성하는 거 크리트 테이블 데이터를 생성해서 넣는 거 인서트 이런 개념으로 데이터를 할 수 있다.
대표적인 소프트웨어들 데이터베이스들은 마이애스케일 포스쿨의 마리아 오라클 오라라.
여기는 좀 주로 정형 디비들, RDB 개념만 좀 넣었습니다.
왜냐하면 이렇게 데이터베이스 테이블을 만들고 테이블에 넣고 이런 개념은 기존의 RDB에서 주로 썼던 개념이기 때문이고요.
물론 비정형에서는 컬렉션이라든가 다른 표현들을 또 데이터베이스마다 쓰기 때문에 일단 기본적으로는 정형 RDB 기준으로 이해하셔도 좋을 것 같습니다.
그리고 많이 씁니다.
실제 서비스들에서 실제로 많이 사용하는 것이 여전히 RDB이기 때문에 이렇게 이해하시면 좋을 것 같고요.
여기 마이애스케일 워크벤치라는 것이고 이거 말고도 디비버도 있고 여러 가지 툴들이 있어요.
무료로 사용할 수 있구요.
마이애스케일 워크벤치로 해서 데이터베이스를 설치하고 접속을 하는 거 이런 개념이 있고
또 접속을 했을 때 이렇게 처음에는 안 보일 수 있어요.
시스 정도만 있을 수 있는데 이런 식으로 하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯.
이게 데이터베이습니다. 아까 설명드렸던 논리적으로 나뉘어지는 개념이고
요 안에 테이블.
테이블 있는 거예요.
그래서 멤버스와 프로덕이라는 테이블이 있는 상태인 거고요.
멤버스에는 요런 식의 컬럼이 있다라는 거예요.
ID, name, username, email, password, role.
프로덕 안에는 ID, name, price, stock.
요런식으로 컬럼이 있다.
그럼 컬럼은 요기죠. ID, name, price, stock.
그리고 여기가 레코드 하나씩 있다라는 겁니다.
대표적으로 요구의 스케일 문이에요. 요런 형태가.
셀렉트 모든 거. 모든 걸 가져와라.
From, shop, db, 여기 데이터베이스의 프로덕.
프로덕 테이블에서 모든 걸 가져와라.
그래서 요렇게 보여지는.
물론 이것은 제가 넣었던 부분이 있기 때문에 이렇게 보여지는 거고요.
여기는 이제 sql 공부한다라는 개념으로 좀 접근하시면 되고
sql 문장들을 좀 보시면 되는데 예를 들면 인서트를 한다.
그러면 인서트, 인투, shop, db, 프로덕.
name 있죠, price 있죠, stock 있죠.
ID는 대개는 오토어 인크리즈먼트라고 해서
자동 증가 값을 많이 씁니다.
그러다 보니까 여기에 안 넣어도 되죠.
밸류스라고 하고 여기 하나씩 넣어주면 돼요.
키보드, 노트북, 신제품, 마우스가 없네요.
꼭 마우스를 넣지 않아도 되고 이 샘플입니다.
stock은 10개 정도.
그리고 컨트롤 엔터.
그리고 한번 조율해 보죠.
그러면 마우스까지 딱 들어간 게 보이죠.
이게 이제 데이터베이스에 데이터를 넣은 거예요.
그리고 만약에 sql의 조건을 달고 싶다.
그러면 웨어라고 해서 많이 쓰는 게 웨어에 아이디에 13번.
이렇게 가져와라.
그러면 13번만 가져오네.
그리고 많이 쓰는 게 업데이트.
shop, db, 프로덕에.
뭐 set, stock이.
지금 10개였다가 뭐 줄을 수 있죠.
9개로.
where, 아이디는 13.
그러면 한번 블루어보면 9개로 줄어있죠.
자, 마지막으로 딜리트.
딜리트 from shop, db의 프로덕.
where, 아이디는 13.
이렇게 하면 삭제.
그러면 다시 보면 없죠.
다른 것들은 그대로 있죠.
자, 이런 식으로 이게 물론 가장 간단한 sql 문장들이고
여기에 뭐 조건이 좀 다양해질 수 있고 또 뭐 조인 같은 게 있을 수 있고
복잡해지지만 그것은 이제 필요하신 분들이 조금 더 깊게 공부하시면 됩니다.
그러니까 제가 이제 취지는 이게 데이터베이스라는 개념을 좀 이해하십사 하는 것이고
뭐 ai로 개발을 하시든 자기가 이제 공부를 하시든 누구든 좀 이 정도까지 알게 됐을 때
조금 더 공부를 해볼 만한 부분이니까 이렇게 이해하시면 될 것 같고
데이터베이스에 대한 개념 그리고 간에서 가장 중요한 것들을 좀 다뤄봤습니다.
여기까지 좀 이해가 되셨다면 좀 sql 문장 그런 것들을 좀 자세히 공부하시거나
직접 해보시는 것 추천드리고요.
ai로 개발하시더라도 이런 개념을 좀 이해해 두시면
실제 데이터가 저장되는 것을 확인해 보면서도 개발할 수 있기 때문에
유용할 거라고 생각이 됩니다.
다음에도 또 클라우드랑 몇 가지 주애들이 있습니다.
기대해 주시고 기다려 주시면 좋은 영상으로 찾아뵙겠습니다.
감사합니다.